bienvenidos nuevamente ahora voy a
resolver este mismo problema pero ahora
vamos a usar números y aunque es algo
poco prolijo siempre es bueno verificar
nuestros resultados con datos reales y a
veces ustedes pueden resolver un
problema sin tener que complicarse con
las variables entonces Bueno vamos a
elegir Algunos números vamos a hacer un
espacio aquí para
escribir nuestros valores digamos que
Nuestra fuerza cero va a ser igual a 10
New
eh nuestra masa
cero va a ser igual a 2
kg y nuestra
aceleración va a ser igual a 5 m por
segundo al
cuadrado esto es del primer sistema
ahora los datos de mi de mi otro sistema
eh tenemos que va a ser la aceleración
cuando tengo unas la masa uno agregada a
la masa dos mi aceleración subíndice 1
va a ser igual a una quinta parte de la
aceleración subíndice cero y aquí lo que
quiero saber es cuánto es la masa uno
cuánto
vale Bueno entonces sustituimos
directamente en nuestra fórmula y nos va
a quedar que la fuerza de 10 newtons que
va siendo la misma en ambos sistemas va
a ser igual a
la masa que es la masa un que no sabemos
más la masa C Que es de 2
kg por nuestra aceleración 1 que es una
quinta parte de aceleración c la
aceleración 0 Son 5 m por segundo
cuadrado entre 5 es igual a 1 m por
segundo
cuadrado y bueno las unidades aquí son
correctas vamos a dejarlas un momento de
lado para hacer las operaciones sabiendo
que de todas maneras el resultado aquí
estará en
newtons Entonces tenemos que son 10 = a
M1 +
2 por 1 que bueno esta la puedo dejar de
lado despejo mi masa 1
+ 1 es igual a resto -2 en ambos lados
de la ecuación 10 - 2 =
8 y ahora sustituyo lo que quiero saber
ya tengo mi masa uno Quiero ver cuál es
la relación entre ambas
masas Y entonces tengo que mi masa cer
entre mi masa 1 mi masa cer es de 2 kg
entre mi masa 1 Es de 8 lo simplifico y
es igual a un cuarto que es lo mismo que
obtuvimos en el video
anterior y como ven esto estuvo mucho
más sencillo que hacer todo este
desarrollo vamos a hacer otro problema
me parece que van a encontrar este
problema bastante interesante digamos
que tengo a un
paracaidista y Aquí lo tengo que acaba
de saltar del
avión y vamos a decir que esta persona
pesa 70 kg tiene una masa de 70
kg y está cayendo o tiene una velocidad
terminal hacia abajo
de
120 millas por
hora millas perdón sí millas por
hora Esta es su velocidad termin
Y esta es un dato correcto para los
paracaidistas es la velocidad que
normalmente alcanzan antes de abrir su
paracaídas y bueno vamos a hacer la
conversión de unidades Ya que queremos
calcular fuerza en newtons Entonces esta
cantidad en millas por hora va a ser
igual a
53.6 m por
segundo Bueno vamos a
eh calcular cuál es la fuerza de la
resistencia del aire cuando esta persona
está
cayendo Bueno antes les tengo que poner
el dato que tiene aquí una velocidad
terminal de
53.6 m por segundo pero ustedes se
preguntarán bueno Qué es la velocidad
terminal cuando ustedes caen o se dejan
caer de un avión eh tienen un montón de
aire que les empuja tienen mucha
resistencia del aire que ocasiona
fricción y los detiene un poco en su
caída de hecho este es el principio de
los paracaídas que al abrirse crean una
mayor resistencia al aire y los va
deteniendo Bueno la velocidad terminal
es aquella en la que ya no pueden ir más
rápido es la velocidad en la que dejan
de acelerar y ya no pueden caer con
mayor
velocidad en la velocidad terminal la
aceleración es igual a cero y sabemos
que la fuerza del aire que podríamos
Llamar fuerza aérea en este caso la
fuerza del
aire Es Exactamente igual a la fuerza de
gravedad que es la que está haciendo que
mi paracaidista caiga mi fuerza de
gravedad al menos Estos son iguales
cuando estamos en una velocidad
terminal Cómo sabemos esto porque el
paracaidista ya no está acelerando en su
velocidad terminal va a gran velocidad
pero mientras más ha acelerado y más
rápido ha caído mayor es la resistencia
del aire hasta que llegue un punto en el
que ya no puede ir más rápido en este
caso la fuerza del aire Es igual a la
fuerza de la
gravedad y sabemos que bueno la fuerza
de la gravedad va a ser igual a la masa
del hombre que son 70 kg por la
aceleración de la gravedad que sabemos
que es
9.8 m por segundo al cuadrado
aproximadamente y hacemos esta operación
y nos va a quedar
New bueno la segunda parte de este
problema es interesante supongamos que
ahora el
paracaidista en lugar de estar cayendo
así acostado ahora va a plegar sus
brazos al cuerpo y se va a dejar caer de
cabeza iría más o menos
así con sus brazos pegados al cuerpo y
cayendo ahora su velocidad terminal
cuando está cayendo así ya no es la
misma Ahora su velocidad terminal es
igual a 180 millas por
hora que esto equivale a aproximadamente
5 Met por
segundo Bueno ahora va mucho más rápido
que cuando estaba acostado digamos que
un 30% más veloz Por qué Porque ahora es
más aerodinámico cuando caía acostado
tenía mayor superficie expuesta al
viento y a la resistencia al aire En
cambio cuando está cayendo de cabeza
solo la superficie de su cabeza es la
que está poniendo la resistencia al aire
por por lo tanto su cabeza es la que
está rompiendo el viento y nada más y es
por eso que gana mayor velocidad eh
cuando la fuerza de resistencia al aire
igual a la fuerza de la gravedad ahora
Cuál será la fuerza que la resistencia
al aire estará ejerciendo en este
paracaidista voy a dejar que piensen en
ello un momento incluso Les recomiendo
si quieren pausen el video para que
piensen al respecto un poquito y ahora
que que le quitaron la pausa les diré
que esta es una pregunta con trampa
porque de nuevo el paracaidista ha
alcanzado su velocidad
terminal es una nueva velocidad terminal
y por definición en este punto el
paracaidista ya no está acelerando su
aceleración aquí de nuevo vuelve a ser
cero y por lo tanto la fuerza del aire
Es igual a la fuerza de la gravedad y
eso ya lo habíamos calculado esta fuerza
es de 686
New ya que ya sé que ustedes estarán
pensando que esto no tiene nada de
sentido Pues él ahora está cayendo mucho
más rápido entonces Pues suena lógico
que el aire eh ejerza más fuerza en él
pues no ya que el aire ejerce la misma
fuerza si la velocidad aumentó mientras
estaba acostado estaría de acuerdo en
que el aire ejerciera más fuerza en él
pero la velocidad cambió cuando la
posición de este paracaidista
cambió cuando va de cabeza Ah va a mucho
más velocidad y pasa más viento
alrededor de esta persona de su cabeza
pero está presionando en una superficie
mucho más pequeña y no voy a entrar en
detalles con respecto a la presión pero
quiero que les quede claro este concepto
Así que aunque aquí el viento va mucho
más rápido lo hace en un área mucho más
chiquita y lo mismo ocurre con la fuerza
y eso lo sabemos porque este en este
momento ya dejó de acelerar pues alcanzó
su velocidad terminal Así que
reflexionen un poco sobre esto es una
pregunta con trampa pero creo que les
ayudará a comprender Qué es la
aceleración Qué es la velocidad terminal
y esto comenzará a ayudarles a
comprender lo que es la resistencia al
aire y la presión nos vemos en el
siguiente
video